what's up everybody uh we've been locked
up for a long time and now i'm finally
getting on the road again so i hope to
see you uh me and chrissy d if you don't
know will be in dallas san antonio
houston st louis columbus and on new
year's eve in cincinnati that's the
whole week after christmas uh and then i
will be on tour solo in des moines
indianapolis cleveland san diego la
burlington a second show added at
foxwoods detroit pittsburgh albany
washington dc which is really tyson's
virginia madison wisconsin and chicago
uh all in jan in february all of those
are on sale right this second at
savocanocomedy.com
can't wait to see you guys god bless
taste buds
they're coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate
talking about the food
they like
four fools gonna fight but only
two fools will be right
taste buds man they're coming to the mic
i'm talking taste buds
taste buds taste buds taste buds lace up
your boots wait put on your boots make
sure they're laced up laced up taste
buds taste buds taste buds taste buds if
you don't watch your purse
they'll take your pay stubs
live performance first ever i almost
forgot the lyric
live performance by the originator and
writer of the song casey jost in the
house thank you thank you i can't snap
you either really
also other guests today big j okerson
our dear friend yeah anybody this is a
first ever
event double event on to
tag team it's a two on two tag team it's
the first time we've ever had two guests
and it's also a two on two tag team and
here we go folks welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
buds and we are battling today i want to
tell you something every time we do that
and we've had it we'll win a couple of
guests every guest you're the you guys
are like the fourth set of guests you've
ever had every one of you has made the
exact same face we did that taking it
back a little a little confused and like
okay i guess so you're like the two
enforcer brothers they bring into our
new hockey team you already know each
other
you guys have secret handshakes and
we're like hey remember me from the time
we weren't doing this
he came with the chance i was like i
don't know if this is going to work it
feels a little bit there and the fans
loved it yes i mean they seem to like it
so we're going to keep doing i think
they like it
for the people it irritates okay at this
point but you know that's just how i
roll coming to you live also from joey
roses at 174 rivington street in the
lower east side of manhattan new york
yeah and if you see if you're watching
this we're already open so come on
through we're open wednesday to sunday
it's a social club yeah opening in the
rose room opening we're in the rose room
opening at 12 p.m every day this is our
sort of private area back here for the
people uh we're opening at 12 p.m every
day we close at midnight on wednesday
and sunday and we're open till 2 a.m
thursday friday saturday we got
sandwiches we got booze all of it
affordable please come through sexy here
too thank you it is a little sexy it is
it's nice there's also a little secrets
hit hidden in the wall i saw that that's
fun yeah little little nooks and
crannies arcade machines star wars
arcade machine affordable is relative
also yeah
where people are at in their lives yeah
yeah we wanted to give back where
they're flying from
conveniently located across the street
from sexy children out of school
as i walked as i walked up i'm like oh a
bar crushed tree from a playground
that's cool that's your thing it's not
across the street
like luring them in with sandwiches like
the thing they eat every day well we
have a spare
[Laughter]
it's funny because paul uh my partner
paul italia goes uh he goes
he goes you know man uh
they got the schools right there that's
probably good for us i go they're
children paul and he goes no for the
sandwiches
we can sell the kids sandwiches and i
was like oh okay that is a good idea and
you don't get bread and vodka you get
them addicted now they gotta come back
and this is the only place that serves
underage i believe in the neighborhood
am i right joe
am i correct about that verified great
if i'm wrong but i think it's the only
place it has an id at all
guys can we not
do this please
oh we're only going to do it more now
if you go to the back bathroom and you
know the secret knock
[Music]
growing up in new york italian
restaurants were serving underage kids
like they would you'd have to drink like
red wine they were serving underage kids
like they were serving white clam pies
so clearly this everywhere they said
the corner of my block got nailed for uh
serving underage be careful joe i don't
know if i agree with your pulse
we are checking ids
everybody you don't have to overstate
that now you're killing the joke
everyone knows auto no vax card needed
not checking fox cuts no that's not true
also in the rose room insulated so no
one can hear you scream
i i want to just say
i want to add like a real lame one like
you use msg
yeah
also sandwiches little salt
sandwiches are perfect
they're good see that's maybe the thing
you say to help your buddy get his
business rolling yeah
i told you it's sexy i'm the only friend
you got thanks casey sandwich brings the
children the booze keeps them here
now you just can't leave video games
there's video games to help keep them
here oh video games you want to do this
dance with me old movies
you want to do this dance what do you
mean what are you talking about you got
a lot to lose out of all of us
joe can't kill this is a room circled by
the eyes of his loving family
[Laughter]
anyway
oh god you need to take a [ __ ] zan
i need to take his hand you can't send a
poll out without scrutinizing it for 25
minutes because you're scared a fan is
going to be offended by the wording of
the question in the poll
yeah
i just want to make sure we articulate
the right way so no one has an advantage
what do you like oreos or are you some
ghetto piece of [ __ ] who likes hydrox
yeah
i edit out high drops because i don't
want people to think that you know every
pulse i'll literally go i just
i don't i feel like it's bad if we say
what's better right pop-tarts
because
like you you absolutely do that every
time i do it
wisely so that we don't articulate so
that i i don't get people being like
trying to get a jump on your side yeah i
want to make sure it's even and i don't
want to make people you also understand
what we're actually also worried that
people are going to say their own answer
that people are going to give a [ __ ]
that people are going to trash us you
worry about all those things now we're
about people trashing us at all you a
thousand percent
every time
we're gonna get trolled
i do i do not
i would like to stop everything down and
rebut that with a full full fervor okay
that i guess you just said one thousand
percent every time i worry we're gonna
get trolls and i don't think i'm ever
worried it's single one you say people
are going to give a [ __ ] for xyz you
didn't use the word troll you say people
but then they're going to give a [ __ ]
because all i'm saying is that i want to
word it right so people don't
misunderstand the thing but i'm saying
you start with a thousand percent that's
not a thing yeah i'm saying you often
say people are going to give a [ __ ] you
could have a thousand percent increase
in something though yes yes are you
saying you never say this
no i am i'm you're you're you're mis
you're mis
appropriating what i'm saying
i wish some cool i wish some cool
drinking kids would be here
lighting this party up i wish some
non-vax young underage drinkers
non-vaccinate sound so creepy when you
say children
we are going to have a balance i ever
it's dine in
versus takeout fan suggestion yeah
i don't remember possibly i think it
might have been yeah dining in versus
taking out uh we got a tag team match
today myself and jay oakerson will be
battling for the takeout side and casey
jost joe derosa will be battling for
dining in yes
sir
oh yeah i forgot i'm sorry
this is why we do this which is not
really that's why this guy's cut they
don't know what happened earlier
some things happened
sorry i'm a little stressed
uh
opening a business how dare i you know
what help call me a little bit
i won't say it
whatever happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you
it works it helps it helps i love it it
does help all right
ready we all have to get into a little
heated beforehand and afterwards
sometimes he goes home and we don't know
if we're really fighting or not wow yeah
he likes to chant that at the beginning
and it sets the tone that hey all right
ready yeah here we go
b-a-t-t-l-e butts all right he's with
the chances and we're off i love it i
love the chance i love it i didn't like
it now i love it all right fans love it
we all embrace it but he's with the
chance that's excuse me because everyone
everyone looks at me the same like what
is going on and why are you chanting
that and i just said oh you're just on
my eyeliner if i was sending her cases i
would make those faces of joe no i made
a different face i made a face that's
like
am i supposed to yeah do we do it
it's like being a jewish person that's
what people say grace before dinner
you're like what is happening right okay
it's that you're so fast to roll over on
the chance when a guest is here i'm not
rolling over but you'll go you'll go
thank you pimp thank you pimp i am not
crazy
i want to give you where they came from
when someone has a reckless abandon with
an inside joke loud in the place you're
like okay we don't do that here
i'm more that person i'm like we let's
not do that um okay so we got we got
dinan versus takeout
uh
you know what let's casey let's give the
floor
to the take out jump at any time
take out why don't you start us off at
why
i mean i know you guys so well at this
point i know why takeout is your pref
well first i can't speak for sal but i
bet we have the same thing i don't like
people to watch me eat and i think
because i'm fat people are going to
watch me eat and just have like a look
at them go attitude about it
so also
so also
also i'll eat like
a bird but i really won't go for it
sitting down at a restaurant i'm a
ritualistic
set it up
smoke a joint before uh
before
tv and just something i'm gonna watch
that i'm gonna dig into and just it's so
ritualistic for me i they can't
possibly please me like that inside of a
restaurant i agree i would say that i
love going out to eat but if i had to
choose one against the other i will
always take if i had if it's like which
one do you choose and prefer and like
better it's takeout because i love too
there's nothing better for me than being
in the comforts of my own home
uh having the same exact meal experience
i'm gonna have for the most part less
the ambiance and service of the
restaurant but i like to maybe smoke a
little bit or i like to uh light a fire
and i like to put on what i like to eat
i like to have my blanket around i just
all the comforts of home walk away from
it for a minute walk away come back
put the rest in the fridge come back
have speak to who i want to speak to
listen to what i want to listen to
whatever music i want whatever
television show i want back and forth
like a caged tiger pretending i'm not
going to go back and eat what christine
leaves
uh you know the restaurant i love it
it's a good experience to eat now
sometimes it's excellent service you get
you do have risk though you got you have
terrible service you have terrible
ambiance i've been in a place where i'm
liking the food and they're playing like
euro house and i want to just literally
rip my nuts out yeah okay i also i
haven't even dipped into the fact that
because i won't i'm judging this like on
my lifelong thing not that
i'm in the public and people because
that's that's just horrific because i
can't go out to eat without people like
pointing watching video and all that
stuff i'm not even putting that on the
table i'm talking about everybody else's
experience basically yeah you're going
to come down to like the yeah the little
people yeah
you're going to come down sometimes
he'll do that sometimes he'll come down
off this big cloud that he lives on i
don't make him cut this and
[Music]
sometimes he'll come off as a cloud
where he
[Music]
acts like a normal person again it's a
clown yeah you can leave it in that's
lawless society nobody believes i do
that that's absurd dude it's a joke
whether it's funny or not it's up to you
he said it came out of his mouth the
clouds are like the ocean man
everything's legal there
everything you just said there were some
very valid points what you both said but
to me it just sounds
sloth-like
it sounds very
take me as i am it sounds right
well we we we're we plan on doing a lot
of takeout business i'm i'm a takeout
fan it's convenient but
everything you just said to me sounds
very much
take me as i am
i don't want to have to live in a
society i
want to i want it to be my own rules i'm
negan
with my spiked bed
and i do food my way i think
eating in are you are you arguing for us
then no oh no you're making great points
no no but my point is this i love a nice
delivery all right but let's talk about
when delivery goes wrong you talked
about all the pros of takeout doesn't
necessarily mean delivery let's okay but
the drive it doesn't matter you're
transporting food from one place to
another before you eat it nine times out
of ten reheating has to come into the
mix which changes nine times out of ten
not nine times out of ten 50 50
yeah because that was my first thought
too my my main argument is there are
foods you should not take out for sure
you know it fish
steak i think a lot of cooking right
yeah it either keeps cooking or when it
arrives it's going to be cold and it's
just it's the worst version of food the
meal should come out of the kitchen hot
people complain when they're at a
restaurant and it comes out a little
cold okay so imagine you're ordering
that same dish to your do your casa i'll
tell you what though
you do it though i agree if you're
ordering you know how to do it i'm not
going to order dishes that couldn't call
it
well
you wouldn't order what dishes that come
shanghai
but how do you know well like he said
there's staples that come stream god and
i i would i would avoid those
yeah
but i feel like
i feel like
i feel any dish any dish even something
as simple as french fries does not
travel well
it's the wendy's who guarantees hot and
fresh fries or they'll replace them yeah
wendy's everyone it's a bold that is a
bowl they're also guaranteeing the flaky
biscuit now yeah bold
on wendy's part i'm gonna bring
something up that you know let's face it
everybody it is tough to buy gifts for
people on the holidays and harry's makes
the perfect gift uh i have harry's
razors i use them they have been better
than any of the races i've bought in the
store in the past they're just they feel
more sturdy they last longer i love them
um
this year give them harry's there's no
better gift than their limited edition
holiday shave sets featuring their
award-winning winston handle that's one
of the things i like very ergonomic plus
handsome and ready to gift packaging for
an amazing unboxing moment so you don't
have to buy the wrapping paper they're
making it easy for you harry's is the
gift that keeps on giving the sharp and
long lasting blades are still as low as
two bucks each when it's time to finally
replace them uh for a limited time this
is cool our listeners of the show can
get five dollars off any holiday shave
set at harry's dot com slash taste buds
high quality and fair prices harry makes
sharp blades at last backed by their 100
quality guarantee so if the person
you're given to do doesn't like it you
get a full refund this holiday season
listeners get five dollars off plus free
shipping on any harry's limited edition
holiday shave set when you go to dot com
taste buds the sets come with a weighted
handle
i like that feel i'm telling you it
makes a difference three razor
cartridges foaming shave gel and a
travel cover everything he'll need for a
smooth shave or she all packaged in a
handsome holiday gift box
to claim your five bucks off plus free
shipping go to harry's dot com slash
taste buds
between small talk at the company
holiday party this season and enjoying
all the holiday treats your mouth does a
lot this time of year gifted better oral
care with quip makers of the
award-winning electric toothbrush uh
when you save up to 40 on holiday
bundles it's also a gift to give your
wallet i have equip i've been using it
even before they were uh part of a
sponsor i take it on the go um at a home
uh i use it but it just has a little
travel case and when i'm on the road
doing comedy it comes with me just like
a regular toothbrush it's not bulky like
other toothbrushes the quip electronic
toothbrush is loved by over seven
million mouths
timed sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses to give a dentist recommended two
minute clean you do each quadrant 30
seconds it's also a fun little treat
lightweight and sleek design adults and
kids could use it there's no wires bulky
charges to weigh you down how do you
like that i said it before they even
told me multi-use travel cover doubles
as a mere amount for less clutter
reusable handles and a range of sleek
metal hues including best-selling all
black and all pink
let's see what else here
in addition to brush heads equip also
delivers fresh floss
toothpaste mouthwash and gum refills
every three months from five bucks
shipping is free so you can save money
and skip the hustle and bustle of
shopping in store during the holidays
and into the new year gotta love that i
do not to be anywhere in those
brick-and-mortars right now if you go to
quip uh if you go to get quip dot com
slash taste buds right now on top of
their holiday savings you get the first
refill free good deal that's your first
refill free and up to 40 off their
bundles at get quip dot com slash taste
buds that's
g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com slash taste buds
quip
the good habits company to to jump on to
what you just said
now does that count as takeout like if
you if you go in your car and you get
wendy's and you eat it in your car that
is also take out yeah so that's that you
guys are lucky you got that well i'm not
because i'll tell you what i'll argue
against you're not eating in you're
taking it out i'll argue against
in a second i am
very anti-eating in the car oh yeah i
hate it yeah i don't i don't choose
there's no don't get that home pleasure
in that in any way whatsoever
and it drives me nuts when you get take
out with somebody and they'll be like in
the passenger seat it goes i gotta eat
like one of these burgers real quick i'm
starving you're like okay well this
wasn't the plan
because we'd go in line with what i
thought we were gonna do but okay this
wasn't that i think it's your car before
too in your back seat yeah but i uh
a long drive is different thing if we're
getting food and just going i get yeah
that was a road difference but also the
quality will be better in that it takes
away our argument in terms of like the
freshness and the hotness if you are
eating in the car like some monster
then you will have better food i'm
thinking more of like a place which just
stopped doing takeout recently quality
italian but we've ordered when they were
when they were i went i i dined in
equality time this week yeah if when
they uh that says it all what just said
they stopped doing takeout why because
the food cannot keep right on compromise
but i ordered from them
when they were i guess from covid and
the quarantine and everything and they
did deliver and it was uh
pretty fantastic they're unbelievable i
ordered from pasta dinner take out all
the time i'll tell you that pasta pasta
take out from the nicest place
the nicer the place for italian food
they also know
that it will come yes ready to go we got
a
tony dinopolis or something from the
upper west last weekend and like stuff
coming sometimes microwaves
yeah i agree that's that's that's good
they'll do it right they package it
right there's no spillage let me talk
about paying dine-in prices for a
delivery for let's talk about that let's
talk about that you're also not if you
go out and have a gorgeous meal just uh
you go out and you spend a hundred bucks
on yourself not that i don't i worked in
the service industry i over tip since
i'm a child but
really when i say i'm a child i was a
teenager
since i was a child
you didn't understand what i meant by
the word child i meant 17 years old
when you were 17 were you kids so i
delivered pizza and i i lived off a tip
so when i ordered pizza i weigh over i
overtipped myself for the show i'll just
back that up with facts so what there
was a child that was the funny part
because you said since i was a child we
all laughed because child sounded funny
i thought we were staying away from
children yeah
they
when i was 16. that's what's the funny
thing i feel like if a 16 year old
walked in there i'd be like that's your
child a kid
that's not split here
it was funny
so it was the beginning
oh you you're not on my clown right now
wait wait wait so you're saying we're
going to dinner
a premium a premium because you're
adding at least i mean twenty percent
but i
the way i tip two is that you're adding
30 40.50 to that meal okay that's that's
another thing sure nothing that happens
to me if you want to say nine out of ten
times it comes
not good i'll tell you what happens to
me
more than five out of five times at a
restaurant i sit next to the loudest
most annoying people in the world and i
cannot enjoy i cannot have a normal
conversation i cannot enjoy my meal in
peace i can't even hear the radio some
places are sold out in general but a lot
of times i'll sit next to two people
they're like well then
put a pin in that because i sent the
email over to david and the vice
president said that i'm not gonna shut
the [ __ ] up that happens so rarely
it happened so much to me uh especially
a place where like
a nicer place where people are
discussing business and they're cutting
loose in a suit right something
i can't tell you how infrequently i've
encountered that and i go and i'll take
it a step further i go out to eat alone
sometimes i love it i'll go to a
four-star steakhouse
and sit down by myself get a steak
bottle of wine
myself oh this is not something well
it's called how it helps it works this
is the culture we live in you know what
an old man does when his wife
do you dies the otb after that
yeah i i i'm sorry i take it home and
turn out all the lights
smoke three [ __ ] bong hits and then
watch it in front of a goddamn episode
oh i want to go to this restaurant oh
let's go they have great food
ah they only have a reservation for two
at 10 45 p.m
but that's because you at the last
minute excuse me we're not taking walk
[Music]
can we talk about cocktails yeah okay
okay
i mean there's nothing like hitting that
bar you go to
are you making your own cocktails i mean
some people do i do all the time too
much but you know it's nice to just sit
back and let someone make your car a
fresh
bar experience it's not good that is
true but also at home you can do it
however you like you know how you like
if you have this stuff but it's also
about having the stuff in your house but
uh you got sweet vermouth
but to go back to uh the tipping thing
here's one thing i will say
on our own argument there's a little bit
of a
a stress i think i over do it i hope
anyway but
tipping sitting in you know what you're
tipping you're giving like at least 20
if not more percent
uh when you do take out i don't know
what the standard is on that i have no
idea what it seems ridiculous to give
them like if you get again like a
takeout from like a quality attempt or a
place like that a nice place if there's
a little being a hundred and some
dollars two hundred something dollars
sometimes i not delivering 20
no like if they come with a bag of food
i'll give twenty bucks just twenty
dollars yeah sure i see i this is i
think we're all gonna be all over the
place because especially like if you
order with seamless sometimes there's a
delivery fee and i'm like do i include
that with my tip and then there's like
the 10 15 20 percent and i'm always just
like this time
15. do they know how to get them switch
it every time based on they know how to
get me if you do 18 on delivery they're
like you're a rock star
and then like if you do 20 they're like
you just helped a kid with cancer
like they're so proud of you that you
can't just do like like the first tips
really just goes like
thanks
right like that like there's already
next to it it says like uh how they'll
feel about your tip percentage you ever
see that oh
yeah it's like eighteen percent yeah
yeah yeah
twenty percent you're a good guy i think
it's the most disgusting thing that's
ever happened to tapping yeah yeah
really stop caps started making yeah
they started twenty percent yeah and
they have the curb app
and they're like 15
i'm talking about a different situation
on the road a lot there's a big thing
right the road you're like wow denny's
is horrible but i'll just grab a super
bird and take it back to my place i
order from that lady right there i think
p.f chang's to go a lot where you're
right there
but i'm going to bring it back to my
hotel you're picking it up in the
restaurant in the restaurant do you
leave it don't know what to do i i i
overdo it but it's not depending on how
much 20 percent because that's not crazy
no way it's a flat fee it's a flat fee
on a pickup
depending on what it is five ten twenty
bucks five ten twenty if you're picking
up two hundred dollars worth of twenty
bucks
if it's a if it's one little meal extra
five just throw it together yeah ten if
it's medium that is the thing who does
it go to because if it's just the person
like who who gives you the food they
they probably didn't do it i act like
everyone pulls their tips everywhere i
go
i've answered i've asked that before but
i mean like a lot of places do i think a
lot of places like the stand does that i
think so it kind of doesn't give it to
you
hey i'd love to love to tip whoever
cause you're rocking the kitchen you're
getting 200 worth of food you're that
that kitchen's taking a hit like you
know which is you know another thing why
you shouldn't do takeout i very agree
what if it's a slow night and all of a
sudden we come in with a 200 takeouts
yeah no you're right is that why they
have cocaine
so much
is that what the cocaine and kitchens is
for
i'm watching intervention las vegas
everybody seems to be a chef who got
hooked on drugs yeah by the way jill
love the cocaine at the spot it's really
top-notch but we try we try to deliver a
nice break
not a little not even a little bit of
fentanyl and it's really yeah who's your
who's your secret investors nicaraguans
the bathroom floors in here do look
pretty studio 54 if you take a look at
them
i just did a urination i was very
pleased with the gold walls and the
glittery floor finish i thought it uh i
thought you upped your game because not
a lot of people people sometimes will do
the whole thing but then the bathrooms
are standard your bathroom split the
vibe which i appreciate also mirrored
ceilings so as i was peeing
i looked up and i watched my p stream
going to the bowl and all the glitter
around me it was a nice experience
a mirrored ceiling again this is big guy
[ __ ] you won't understand you'll never
look better in your life than looking up
in a mirror and takes away all this yeah
can i tell you unless you're laying down
looking a good mirrored elevator when
you're by yourself yeah and i look up
there i go i hope this is how i look to
everybody else yeah can i tell you to
the aliens to the aliens
i gave some pushback paul paul wanted to
do the mirrored ceilings i gave a little
pushback i was like do we really need to
do that he was like yes because if you
show people you care about the bathrooms
it shows you care like i agree with that
part about it it sounds like
restaurants you know dining in gives you
a conversation piece which is another
topic like you're sitting down sure
great point
there is a great idea i just came back
from the beginning
so much
whenever i dine i play a game with my
lady and we're always we do like a whole
thing like ambiance so let's rate it
service let's rate it yeah food let's
rate it let's rate each course let's
rate the bathrooms we do it all yeah we
do it all it's fun i know you know i
know that's that is i do do that dining
is fantastic and all that is great and
the ambiance and everything until you
find out somebody put toilet cams in
now how do you answer for yourself we're
not saying that's happening here i'm
gonna say it's happening here i'm just
saying the availability is there to put
it in the toilet camp they make them
smaller than ever now and if you're ever
gonna do it you're gonna do it when
you're building the place around opening
day
well it's the best way to hide
in plain sight
they're asking yourself
fast food that's good would i eat in for
mcdonald's
does your taste change if you're talking
about fast food well do you like dining
in over taking out on facebook never had
a problem with eating in a fast food
restaurant especially if i'm on a road
trip i love to go sit in the barbies get
out of the car stretch your legs yeah
chick-fil-a or whatever i love it but i
also love this is one of the only times
i prefer take out to dine in i would do
like eating in the car i love riding on
that open road with a nice burger
i
presents
like it but i'll never i'll never choose
sitting in the if it's my choice
never choose to sit in like the fast
food
dip off on the side of the road one it's
a cruel game they play by serving the
most fattening food making booze made
simply for children uh i don't like
eating fattening foods in front of
people while my boobs are on the table
and that's not my doing that's because
they make they make those tables don't
move yeah they're bolted in tell you
what that's the first thing i look at
when i go to any restaurant i go i'm
picturing you guys are these moves
i move this to the table if that thing's
bolted to the ground i go we'll take a
high top
jay i'm picturing you going straight to
the ball pit and like eating your big
mac and just for the room you're just
like
i don't think i've eaten
at least willingly i don't think so
inside of a
fast food place and sat down and eaten
there since there was tinfoil ashtrays
on every table yeah it's oh remember
that wait those were the days
those were the days
early 90s
early 90s i got to walk away from the
battle for a minute hey
i'm opening a bar wow hey taste buddies
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
pretty much all the time at this point
we love them is there something
interfering with your happiness
preventing you from achieving your goals
probably all of us go through that
better help will assess your needs and
match you with a licensed professional
therapist in under 48 hours not a crisis
line it's just professional counseling
and it's done secure and it's done
online they have experts from all areas
and since it's online you'll get access
to experts that you wouldn't get your
local area they have clients worldwide
better help want you to start living a
happier life today
okay visit betterhelp.com tastebuds
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
join over a million people who've taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experience of mental health
sorry about that with the help of an
experienced professional sorry about
that my mental health is a little
strange right now myself i'll be jumping
on better help pretty soon special offer
for our listeners taste buddies get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds all right guys since you're
listening to this show i think it's safe
to say you love listening to podcasts
right or at least this one i wouldn't
assume you like any other one besides
this one maybe hey babe
you'll find a ton of binge-worthy
podcasts including this one on amazon
music they have more than 10 million
free podcast episodes to listen to so if
you got the time they got the podcast uh
listed a hilarious podcast smart less
one week before everyone else and ad
free on amazon music the breathtaking
true
true crime podcast dr death miracle man
which i've heard about i want to check
that out is available two weeks early on
amazon music but it's not just for
podcasts they have thousands of music
stations and top playlists to stream
again for free no matter what you're
listening to you can go hands-free with
alexa
that lovely lady if you're like me and
you want your music on demand and
ad-free you got to try amazon music
unlimited that gives you unlimited
access to over 75 million songs podcast
music videos and more amazon music
unlimited you can listen to any song
anywhere offline with unlimited skips um
yeah we've been listening to it i love
the unlimited skips because there are
other
music platforms that will go unnamed and
then you skip and uh they only give you
a certain amount and then you hear a
song that you want to punch your face to
and you can't skip it uh not here if you
have never tried amazon music unlimited
now is a great time because for a
limited time new customers can try
amazon music unlimited free for three
months no credit card required just go
to amazon.com tastepods that's
amazon.com
buds to try amazon music unlimited free
for three months amazon.com taste buds
renews automatically cancel anytime
terms apply i've got a flashlight out
there i gotta talk can i can i talk to
you about another thing that we haven't
talked about yet the the uh
the variable that is service when you're
dining in let me tell you something i
give myself a rate service at home i
everything i want is at my fingertips at
my beck and call there's no variable
with bad service restaurants
unfortunately these days it's hard to
find good stuff and here's oh i need my
water has been empty i'm parched i'm
drinking a salty my water's been empty
for five minutes
can i get more water yes please and then
she goes okay but i also wanted to
right it happens all the time
it's our a bit of our own anxiety falls
in this cause i have a bit of that where
i'm like
i i say everything to them as if it's
their burden versus like what their job
is i know i really i'm like i'm so sorry
and by the way that's right in the ass i
did a a
trip to wawa one time down to the shores
coming back from a gig
and i was we're traveling with it
this is never a wawa problem ever this
guy in his 40s i'd say at the time
uh behind the counter was making just
had like a blank stare he's making the
sandwiches and i was like this is before
they had the machines even so you had to
tell them the whole thing yeah and i'm
going to get this i'm going to get all
the toppings though just like put them
on the side because i'm like traveling
with this so if you just put the
toppings on the side that'd be great man
and i go unnecessarily i go i'm sorry if
it's like a pain in the ass so he goes
well it is
wow i was like excuse me and then we had
a whole thing it ended up making me feel
worse at the end he came back he's like
i don't know man he goes i apologize i
shouldn't have said that like that but
like
just 40 something years old i'm working
here in a while
oh yeah yeah i guess this does suck all
right hey man just put the toppings on
the thing he's like no i already put
them but never became like these guys
put it on the sandwich i'll figure it
out i love soggy bread i don't care yeah
i uh that's some darkness though but
just yeah snapping like that on the
thing when you were like again what
bothered me about it is
it's the only times i ever get like
irate with stuff i guess when i feel
like i'm already going like that's what
i said most of my arguments are like
right i have to have a confrontation
with somebody and i still go like i'm
like the hey you you kind of owe me that
two thousand dollars
and they're like why are you bothering
me about that and you're like yeah
that's totally correct i'm that person
completely but in terms of service
though like you know you're waiting for
your food to arrive with the delivery
right and there's definitely tons of
times that it comes quick but tons of
times that it takes a while and you're
hungry and you're home and you're like
do i start eating my own snacks because
the food's not here see i wasn't really
focusing on delivery when we said this i
was focusing on just picking up from a
restaurant taking out yeah but where are
you gonna where are you taking the food
to my house okay yeah yeah or two about
whatever
uh meticulous about the post
where he tried to miscategorize it she
said i don't want people to if we don't
want we don't want delivery included i
want to make sure that they don't
include delivery i think takeout is
everything not eating in the restaurant
yeah yeah you're right
i used to deliver
i used to love a pizza and i did tamper
with one order in five years what are
you talking about uh what do you mean
you tampered with it i tampered with an
order tampered seems like really
innocuous but it's it's a it probably
seems actually ominous yes it is ominous
but tamper's so light it's like pamper
but with the tape and this is like you
just like you touch some lettuce in this
day and age in this day and age in
today's world what i did wouldn't i
wouldn't do you terrorized i
spit no spit on a pizza you don't put a
little before you freak out everyone it
was an asian family
go ahead i'm sorry
no this is what happened right i uh i
had a woman that i used to work at a
pizzeria and i worked there for five
years and every single day she ordered
like two slices and a can of coke and it
was like
two
it was like a dollar ninety it was 295.
okay we're a quick set the scene how old
are you i was 17.
this is staten island i worked i worked
there from
17 to 20. this is the place where you
should you still hang out with the owner
from like when your child
comes to like he comes to joker's like
screenings
this woman would order every single day
two slices we had a delivery minimum and
he he let her her order under it
even the delivery minute was five
dollars i mean
295 every day
every single time i worked i worked four
days a week there for five years i would
drive there i would give it to her and
she would give me 2.95
never tip me she ordered two slices and
she would never ever tip me and she also
was just
if you saw this person she was someone
that would just get under your skin on
sight
she just was unlikable she's heavy too
right she was heavy that had nothing to
do with it does have to do with it two
slices for a woman
it was uh two sicilian slices two
sicilian slices pig with pepperoni
complete pig and uh and a can of regular
coke she deserved that spit she was the
person around your slop pig she was like
she was like a hoarder type too so it
was like it wasn't she was very clean
and and she had a tremor but all her
stuff was just hanging on it she
obviously used it she obviously didn't
like my trouble no she did use it she
would put the pizza on and fire her
mouth she weighed at the end with her
mouth open like a hungry hippo
yeah
she turned it on
she sent
[Laughter]
i don't know it takes a lot of core
strength to stay down there um so and
she also would take forever to come to
the door
so i'd knock and then i ring and that
like this is a long time to wait for the
door it's a long time to wait
two minutes at a door yeah she'd take
[ __ ] two minutes and she opened it
and sometimes she'd put her glasses and
go oh let me go get the money did she
walk her back away from the door
disappear in the kitchen then come back
with exact change did she sometimes have
like an orthopedic hand and wrist thing
on
[Music]
why do you say that that just sounds
like a lady who would
you know wrote a piece of man or
i bet those ankles are discolored
i've seen this lady yeah not this lady
but this lady she had yellow teeth too
which annoyed me why wouldn't she so
you're so
but this is still crazy this is still
for me as your friend this is crazy that
you would still tamp with the peeps so
this is what happened one day this was
when it was the last straw
she
she i i go there again as per usual the
years of me doing this she's never
tipped me anything she now comes to the
door will you take this bag of dead cats
i found other old newspapers out for me
she goes
she comes the door and she hands me a
manila envelope it weighs about
a couple of pounds
and she goes oh sorry i was out of like
cash and she hands me a vanilla envelope
and she puts it in my hand i'm like
okay
and she goes there's something in there
for you she never said that before right
so i was like
okay whoa okay maybe she felt bad that
she's giving me 100 coins
and and you know at what point do you
just not order the pizza yeah you know
if you if you're scrapping around for
corn i'll tell you what i did in my life
when we were broke you know my mom was
in quarters whoa joe's back buddy
quarters my mom was in col my mom went
back to college i think my stepfather
was still we were just broke my
stepfather worked at like gnc or
something to make some money and my mom
started working like low money at a
hospital
and we used to dig in our couch swallow
change we used to do it but my
stepfather was brilliant in this he
would send me the child down with my
shirt
front flipped upside you know with the
change yeah and go down with exact
change for like shitty amounts like five
dollars worth like me and him would get
like that's smart we ordered like two
rolls
and two pieces of fetish like blocks of
feta cheese and like time out like a
piece of feta cheese and a roll we would
eat so it'd be like five bucks but i
would go down there with but he would
send a a kid like a 10 11 year old so
that people just kind of be like
like let me just clarify i paid for
things would change let me finish the
story sorry my pokemon okay
so i get back in the car and i open them
vanilla envelope and it's old jewelry
it's 100 pennies
oh wow okay
100
pennies that's a lot okay i don't i i'd
argue if you're paying with change for
something that's what i mean no pennies
at all well that's what i mean it's like
i don't care if she would have gave me
[ __ ] 12 quarters but like what at
what point when you're scrapping at
hundreds of pennies is it like just
don't order because she also has to give
that to me i have to take it to the
establishment can i guess she gave you
300 pennies she did
no way yes she did i feel like i just
won plinko you finally got a five cent
two i counted that she gave me five
pennies as a tip and she fired she made
a point to say there's something in
there for you no it's 2.95 it was 295
yes
wow and i i thought it was 2.99 and i
and she gave you 300 which was a penny
no no she gave me five cents oh that's
nice okay so then i i was so sure new
york pizza around your dick and balls
so i walked back to the pizzeria
and he already knows that i don't like
going to this lady but he's like just do
me a favor and i always did i always did
with a smile
i walk into the pizza and i open them
and not open they turn it upside down on
the counter it goes [ __ ] just rains
copper it's shooting all over the place
and he goes he goes what is that i go
it's a 295 for the two slices it's uh he
goes come on i go no no no also she
finally gave me a tip and i just pushed
five cents out of it and he goes no she
didn't i go yes he goes all right he
gets her on the phone he calls the bag
goes miss i'm gonna have my guy come
back and bring these pennies back you
give me actual money the actual money
when you have it please
i won't be able to get rid of 300 pounds
that's good currency
that's it
put them in rolls and bring them into
the bag they brought it back you put
them in rolls and bring them together
now he's going to roll it
wait can i just say something just like
the kids can i just say i just clarified
not that it makes much of a difference
but this order was 4.95 not 295. it was
four ninety five so it was five hundred
percent that's a little bit different a
little bit different i remember that i
remember because we went there it was so
many pennies that he's like what am i
supposed to do with all these you should
remember that envelope
can you take us can you take us to the
polls buddy
take us to the polls babe
i wish she said something what what
north or south okay dine in verse
takeout yeah yeah i forgot to
i forgot the delivery thing
yes yeah we had a story on the heels of
takeout oh i love that yeah how does
that impact your hangout
well look i tip well and i don't you
know pay and just pennies and i get
quick to answer the door and uh you know
i'm i i like to think that i present
myself as someone who's likable you
missing a cell once jerked off on
someone's white clam pizza
[Laughter]
which they sell everywhere so it wasn't
which they were like the lady couldn't
even tell she's like i've had this
zillion of these they all seem the same
i can respect
how many votes
uh humble pie segment drum roll on the
pimp pimp's gonna put out the
percentages right now what do you think
guys what do you think who's winning
this what do you think
i think the i think dinan's got a shot
yeah but i definitely think it's going
to be take out just based on like after
this do we think it's going to be close
do we think it's going to be close or is
someone running away with it i think i
think takeout's running away because
people are going to go for the lazy
option i like think takeouts running
away over the world maybe i know but i'm
telling you people
like i've people get upset with me that
it's like hey let's go out to
what on the road if i bring somebody in
the row at me like let's go to lunch
which i'll do because i'm like try to be
a human being but my instinct is if no
one was on the road with me
completely taken away the way you got to
think about this right is if you could
never do takeout again or if you could
never do dine out again which one would
you do
i think that i'd have to go take out
just because of the convenience yeah
i'll never go to how many votes do we
have
eight thousand okay give us the wins
because we gotta wrap up okay okay 47
oh
damn it
damn it and that's not even we don't
know on the laptop this usually breaks
down to percentages so we have a under
three percent win for takeout which is
grounds anything under five percent is
grounds for a rematch
yeah wow they took else today let's do
it right now did you take three out
start over take three hours
let's start over from you this was your
one win right so there's a school across
the street all right
guys that's our show jay you want any
plugs it's bigjaycomedy.com for all my
live dates
casey it's just bigjaycomedy.com
[Music]
savilecanocomedy.com i probably played
my dates at the beginning of this but uh
there i'm on tour and there's dozens of
dates right now and more to be added and
just check out salvador county uh you're
also on a little television show uh
practical jokers
the misery index and then check out hey
babe and uh yeah uh check out my other
podcast we'll see you in hell come to
i'm going on the road starting 2022.
tickets for buffalo helium and bananas
and hasbro kites are on sale now
uh come see me and uh joey roses 174
rivington come on down plug anything i
should plug something yeah yeah if you
want to yeah let me think like uh i'm
trying to think what do i have from the
you know like a myspace or something
like the bonfire
my favorite radio show two episodes ago
oh hell yeah i want to plug something
like um like the macbook pro you know
buy one
all right
all right excellent there you go uh
we still love you babes still love you
too all right
what's up everybody uh we've been locked
up for a long time and now i'm finally
getting on the road again so i hope to
see you uh me and chrissy d if you don't
know we'll be in dallas san antonio
houston st louis columbus and on new
year's eve in cincinnati that's the
whole week after christmas uh and then i
will be on tour solo in des moines
indianapolis cleveland san diego la
burlington a second show added at
foxwoods detroit pittsburgh albany
washington dc which is really tyson's
virginia madison wisconsin and chicago
uh all in jan in february all of those
are on sale right this second at
savolcano comedy.com can't wait to see
you guys god bless
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them